そこで我々はこの何か考える時
この五蘊心が門になっちゃうんですね
五蘊心を変えちゃって考え方が生まれちゃうんです
いわゆる仏教  何役かやってるって
慰問は一つの仕事じゃなくて
今先生が言ってた部分をやって
この門の説明は 慰問は五蘊の働きを言わせちゃいますよね
五蘊自体が慰問であると
頭の回転して他の考えを起こす時はそれとは別の
考え方を起こすとどこに起こしちゃったんで
場所を  それは事実のことで
どこに現れるかで決められる
ただ ここで場所を言ってるんですからね
門言ってるんだからね
入る入り口
タッタパンチャドアラワッジャナチャックヴィンヤーナサンパティッチャナサンティーラナウォッタッパナカーマーバチェラジャワナタダーラッマナヴァセーナチャッ
タリーサチッターニチャックドゥーアレーヤターラハンウッパッジャンテ
そこで慰問という目を門としてしたら
いろんな心が生まれるんだと
ただ眼識だけではない
これ順番に言ってるんですね
まあだから順番に説明します
例えば我々の目に何か入ったと
入ったら目に意識が生まれなくちゃいけないんですね
集中力は目に行かなくちゃいけない
この集中力は目に行ったということは
五門陰転なんですね 五門陰転という心なんですね
五門陰転 目に入って それから見る
それはチャック・ヴィンヤーナというんですね
眼識というんですね そこで目でも眼識が生まれた
生まれた この対象は領受
受ける 領受心という心が生まれる
それから生まれたものは推導
判断しなくちゃいけない
見たものはいいものか悪いものか判断しない
それは推導心がやってしまっちゃう
推導心がそれしたところで
次に必ずも確定心が生まれなくちゃいけない
それで それに従って この即行心という善悪のカルマの心が生まれるんですね
そこは即行心 この場合は欲界の即行心
目は欲界だから 欲界の即行心というのは
まあこっちは二重苦にしているんですね
それから可笑縁も生まれる
それは可笑縁の仕事をする心は八種類あります
それは全部四十六種類の心が目に生まれる
同じく耳にも四十六種類の心が生まれるんだと
耳の中という意味ではなくて
耳を門にして六十四生まれる
目を門にして六十四が生まれると
そこで目を門にしたところで
どれぐらい心が生まれるとこっち書いてますから
まあ慰問陰転と五十五の即行心
即行心全部生まれるし
十一の可笑縁 可笑縁心は全部生まれるし
六十七生まれるんですね
で 一応 それからこの結所
五蘊 識という仕事をする心が全部十九種類なんですね
まあ数えてみるとなんでしたっけ？サンティールナブッタスと
まあ大神八と大浄神九とね
そのあの結晶分質という働きする場合は門がありませんと
で 離門心と言いたがってるんですね
いわゆる門がある場合はここに生命がいるんですね
生命が死んで死ぬ瞬間で心がある
この体でどんな場所に生まれるかといったっても
もう終わりだから この原因B精神に関係なく
最後の瞬間の心が生まれて
この体と関係なく結晶心がまたすぐに生まれしまっちゃうんですね
ですから この離門だから
門から離れているんだから
まあ輪廻はもう不能になるということなんです
例えば心が生まれるというならば
確実に門が必要でしょうと決めてしまったら
もう輪廻転生は不可能になっちゃうんですね
ここで死んだ人がまだ生まれ変わってないんだから
生まれ変わったところで体ができちゃいますから
ですから この結晶心は離門と
門とは関係ないと 十五種類あるんです
そこで確実に一つの門に生まれる心がここでまとめてあって
で パンチャヴィンヤーナ
あの五識 もう決まってるんですね
目には眼識しか生まれません
眼識は他の場所に生まれません
鼻では見ることはできないんだから
そういうふうに場所を決まっている
それからマハッガタロークって
マハッガタチッタっていうのは色界・無色界の禅定の心
それは確実に異門に生まれるんですね
他のところでは生まれません
それから出世間心も でもそれは違うことを言ってるんですけどね
チャッティマヤタランエーカドワールカチッタナと言っていて
まあ一応一門心であると
それから異界というこの心が三つありますね
五門陰転 異門陰転と覚定心というのは
そういうのは ああ 漏出心
あ そうそう 領受心ですね
うん うん で 五門で現れると
ですから この五門因典と
まあ領受心二つ その三つは門が五つに現れるんですね
うーん これはまあややこしいな
ここまで言うべきかと思う
ややこしくて まあ六門に生まれる心があったりして
また門に生まれない心があるという
まあそこら辺そんなもんです
あまり意味がないんです
で まあ七十九ページのアーランマナサンガハム
それもまあそんなに このアーランマナっていうのは大処
こちらは処縁と書いてるんですね
アーランマナ またまあわかっていることで
まあ色・声・香・味・触・法というものなんですね
ですから このその場合は色処縁
まあ声処縁 香処縁と 味処縁
触処縁とか法処縁というだけで
で 六つありますと いわゆるこの認識を現れる時は
まあ情報ですね この認識するいわゆる情報
それは六つに分けてあって
まあそういうことで それからそれに心を分けちゃいますね
サッタルーパンエヴァルーパアランサッタサッダーディワサッダーランマナ
そこでこの あの色・声・香・味・触
そこまではもう明確 目に入るもの
耳に入るもの 鼻に入るもの
舌に入るもの で 明確でないのは法なんですね
法処縁 ダンマアーランマナっていうのは
その場合はこの意に入るもの
心に生まれるものは全部まとめて法処縁と言うんです
だから法っていうのはこのいろんな意味で使ってますから
まあ一般的に現象という意味でも使ってるし
もう物事という意味でね
この場合はまあ心に現れる物事は全部法処縁と言っていて
じゃあそれは何でしょうかと
また具体的に述べてしまうんですね
パサダ・スクマ・ルーパ・チッタ・チェータシカ・ニッバーナ・パンニャッティ・ヴァセーナ・チェダーサンガイハティカ
で どういうものかというと
上色と書いてますね パサダ・ルーパ
で 目で見えるのはある一つの色だけ
あの色は二十八ありますね
二十八の色の中で目で見えるのはたった一種類の色
それはあの色と書いているこのワンナということなんですね
あのチースイカーフーは目で見えません
チースイカーフーをまとめると
あの必ずもワンナ・ガンダ・ラサ・オージャというまた四つの色がついちゃうんですね
ワンナは色 ガンダは香り
ラサは味 オージャっていうのはなんとなく栄養みたいなもの
その四つがついちゃって
八つのグループになっちゃうんですね
だから我々は何かを見る時は
そのチースイカーフーとワンナ・ガンダ・ラサ・オージャという八つのセットの中で
ワンナ 色ということだけ目で見ているんです
その物体が持っている音という物質だけ耳で聞いているんです
ですから 目に入る色はたった一つ
耳に入る色はたった一つと
物質としては一つとももう決まってるんです
ですから このパサードルーパっていうのはまた違うものなんです
それはチャックパサド
チャックソータガーナジフアカーヤパサードとチャックソータガーナジフアカーヤマ
ゲンニービーセッシンに入れてるんです
パサードというもの で
それは説明しましたから
それは心でしか理解できないんですね
目では光に敏感性を持ってるんですね
光っていうか 色に目は敏感
音に耳が敏感 その敏感という働きする何かあるんですね
物質的に 他のところは音に敏感じゃないんだから
例えば神経だからって神経は体中あるんだけど
体中の神経は全部同じですけど
でも音には敏感じゃないんです
耳の神経だけ音に敏感なんですね
で ですからそこは例えば耳が
今は技術的に不可能かもしれませんだけど
耳が聞こえない人がいて
耳の耳は別に悪くないんだったら
他のところからでも神経つなげておけば聞こえるはずなんです
まあ技術的にちょっと不可能だけで
論理的には可能なんです
神経というのは単なる電線と同じものだから
もう切れてるところをつなげておけば
情報はつなげていっちゃうんです
だからといって耳の神経を取って指につけたところで
指で音が聞こえるかというと
そうはないんですね ですから
やっぱり耳の物体的な物体である耳の中になんとかちょっと違う作用があるんですね
音に敏感 そういうのはこのパサードルーパと言うんですね
それは五つあるんです
あって どこを飛んじゃったっけ
その あのパサードルーパという
そういうは理解するのは心で理解しなくちゃいけない
で もう舐めたりすることはできない
舐めてみて あ これは目の敏感性やとかわかりませんだからね
ですから やっぱり心で考えなくちゃいけないんです
それからスクマルーパ
あの二十八の残りの心
全部心で考えなくちゃいけない
それから心 チッタ チェータシカ
心所 そういうものも全部心で理解するものなんですね
それから涅槃 涅槃というものも目で見ることは不可能であって
これは心で認識するものなんですね
それからパンニャッティってなんでしょうか
まあ虚説と書いて いわゆる本当は存在しないもの
でも俗世間では常識 ではあると思うもの
例えば人がいる 木がある
建物があるっていうのは
世俗 世論では正しいし
でも仏教の正義体ではそんなことは存在しないと言ってるんですね
目で見て あれは建物ですよと言っても
目に入るのは色のみ 色だけ入ったところで頭で建物だと判断する
そこでみんな我々人間がそうですよ
そこに建物ありますよと話したりもする
それは人間の世界では真実なんです
仏教の世界では それは世俗体というんですね
俗霊の真実 嘘じゃないんです
で 仏教では正義体というのは
もうこういう厳密に物事を分けたところの真理なんですね
ですから この一般的な我々は人です
女の人です 男の人です
子供ですとかね 理解すること
あれは綺麗な絵ですとかね
これは建物です これは道路ですとか
そういうふうにこの言葉で使っている全ての世界は施説といって
実体はないと 実体ない
その世界も心で判断するものなんです
だから存在しなくても
心にはそれがあると思うことはできます
本当は目で建物は見えません
目にはこのその場所にある色が映るだけ
色が映ったところで頭の中でそれは建物ですと判断する
建物ですということは真実ではなくて
それは世俗体の真実なんですね
正義体の真理ではありません
英語でそれコンベンショナルトゥルースというんですね
まあコンベンション まあそういうふうに決まってるんだと
みんなで決まってるんだから
いわゆる一般常識ということで決まられているもの
それは真理の立場であるわけじゃない
ないんだけど 一般常識ではあるんじゃないかと
建物はあるんだと決める
だからあるんだということにも
別にいろいろ文句言う必要はないし
それはそれでいいということ
で それアビダンマの世界で
この正義体という優れている真理
真理の立場の真理と言っちゃうと
全部この存在をきめ細かくバラバラにしちゃうんですね
何もなくなっちゃうんですね
目で我々はすごい世界を持ってるのに
目で見て勉強するは知識が増えるはありとあらゆることをやってるのに
仏教から見れば何も見てないことになっちゃうんですね
ただ色を認知しているだけではないかと
そうすると あの 仏教をおかしく考える人にとっては
いろいろ遊びやらくだらない話やらいくらでもできるんですね
あなたはここにいる人は見てないんですよと
とも言えるし なぜいえ
人は見えませんだから
そんなことを言ったって
まあ単なるくだらない遊びだけで
ですから こんなくだらないことを言う必要はないんだと
私はそこに人がいると見えてますよっていうのは
それは一般的な真実だよと
真理の立場でそれは違うかもしれませんだけど
一般的にはそれは常識で真実であると
それを認めているんですね
そういうことで 一切階級とかね
そういうふうな この全てはもう有色心のみであるとかね
そういうふうなことは言ってはならんですね
初期仏教というか 上座部仏教の場合は
全ては有色のみと言ったっても
私にとってはもう客観的な建物あるんだから
まあそれでいいんじゃないかと
これは真理の立場で心のみかもしれませんだけど
まあそれはもう後の話だと
ですから この世俗体の真理
世俗のレベル 一般のレベルの真理認めてあげなかったら
人に会話もできないし
喋ることもできないし
生きることもできなくなっちゃうんですね
むちゃくちゃになっちゃうんです
論理は成り立たなくなっちゃう
ですから アンニャッティという施説も認める
人のイマジネーションも
まあそれはイマジネーションですよと認める
ですから 例えば人に ある人に人を見て
その人の頭の上に何か花が咲いているように想像することもできるでしょうし
人の顔を見て まあこの人の顔は馬に似ているんだとかねと思うこともできるし
別にもうだからそこも
それなりに認めてあげる
まあ違う言葉で言えば
心 心所 心一つ 心所五十二
それから色二十八 それから涅槃一つ
それだけが実体ではないんだけど
実際に存在 生滅変化して存在しているんです
それだけ そうすると数えられるでしょうに
どれぐらいものがあるんですかと
心と心所はそこで五十三でしょうに
で 二十八の色 二十八の中でも私の分析ではもう総じて言いましたから
遠い昔なんですけど もう二十八も存在しないんです
実際に存在するのはものすごいまた少ないんですね
ですから この実際に生滅変化の流れに入っている諸行の例で見ると
ほんのわずかなんですね
そこで世界と関係なく涅槃という
もうものがあると 状態
それだけ真理なんですが
それ以外 我々考える世界は全部世説というんですね
ですから まあ正義体は正義体でいいし
世説は世説でそれでいいし
ですから 私たち使っている言葉やら全て世説なんですね
例えば人に名前を付けちゃうでしょうね
あの人は田中さんですよと
それはあくまでも頭だけの働きでしょうに
田中という実体とかなんとかあるわけじゃないし
その人の中でどこを探しても田中たるものは見つかりませんし
田中と言ってもいいし
もう別違う言葉を言ってもいいし
何でもいいんだから だから一人の人にいろんな名前がたくさん付いちゃうでしょうに
もし例えば人に人間と言うでしょ
その場合は我々ある法則があって
こちらは人間で こちらは動物と決まってるんですね
そこで間違ってでも ある一人の人間を動物の中に入れてカテゴリーするっていうことはしないんですね
そちらにいくらかは論理性あるんですね
これは人間 これは動物と
で 人に田中やら何か名前を付けちゃうと
田中でもいいし タモリでもいいし
森田でもいいし どっちでもいいんです
そこであなたの名前ちょっと言いづらいんだから違う名前にしようと
もう勝手に友達とか名前を付けたりもするし
それでまたそれでも通用してしまっちゃうし
だからそういう世界は
我々は別に悟ってから得た知恵でやっていることではなくて
単なる頭で想像してやってるイマジネーションの世界なんです
ですから実体はないんです
何も 実体はないんだからといって
幻覚だからといって それは嘘だ
捨てましょうということにはならないんですね
生きている上にはそれは必要です
ですから それもそれでその通りに認める
それから目では現在の物質しか見え-耳では現在今の瞬間にある物しか見えません
ですから現耳鼻色身は現在今の瞬間のエネルギーを認識する
意はそれと関係ない エネルギーとしてないものを認識するんだから
田中といったら何のエネルギーも持ってないんだから
実体ないんだから でも認識しちゃうんですね
意は だから意の場合は過去
現在 未来と それから存在しないもの全ては認識できるということを言ってるんです
それから この維摩の心は何を認識するでしょうかね
そこはちょっと問題なんですね
マノヴァーリカ チッターナンパニ チャッビダン パッチュッパンナン アティータン アナガタン カーラ ヴィムッタンス
チャ ヤターラハン アラムマナン ホティ
ドゥーラー ヴィムッタンス チャ パティサンジ バワンガ チュティ サンカーターナン チャッビダン ピ ヤターサンバワン エブイエーナ バワンタレ
チャッドゥーラー ガヒッタン パッチュッパンナン アティータン パンニャッティ ブータンワ カッマン カン カッ
マ ニミッタ ガティ ニミッタ サマン サッマタン アラムマナン ホティ
ということなんですけど
説明したがらないですね
で あの維摩っていうのは人が死ぬ時の心ですね
それから生まれる時の心
で 一応死ぬ時の心をちょっと置いておいて
生まれる時の心考えましょう
生まれる時の心っていうのは新しい場所で生まれるんですね
その時は その人は死ぬ前
死ぬ心が現れる前に普通に認識していたんですね
いろんなものを 人と喋ったり考えたりできる
そこでいきなり死の心が生まれて死んじゃったと
死身が生まれた瞬間では
何も見ようとはしない
見ることもできない 有分身だから
だから我々有分身は実感ないでしょ
深く寝たところで有分身でしょうし
起きたとこは知ってますけど
寝たことも知ってますけど
寝ていた間はまるっきり知らない
ですから 有分身っていうのは実感ない心なんですね
一応生きていたことはもう起きたところでわかってるんですね
その間は でもその間生きてたっていうことさえないんですね
だから有分身っていうのはまるっきり無識なんですね
正真正銘の無識 もうどうしようもない
で 死ぬ心も有分身だから
死ぬ瞬間でまるっきり無識なんです
だから死ぬのは怖いとかなんとか思ったっても
それは妄想的で妄想で怖いだけなんですね
実際に死ぬ瞬間っていうのは有分身なんです
何のことなくふわっと終わっちゃうんです
だからその瞬間にただみんなと
例えばぽっくり死ぬ人々でよく喋っていて
いきなりなんとなく意識がなくなっちゃって
何もわけわからなくなっちゃう
それで終わったと 死ぬ瞬間は苦しくないんで
その前は大変苦しいんです
死にたくないと思うとすごい執着あるでしょうに
だから必死になってこの体に心をつなげておこう
つなげておこうと思っちゃうんですね
体がボロボロだから このボロボロ物質に心が触れるたびに強烈に苦しみを感じちゃうんです
だからこの執着捨てれば捨てるほど楽なんですね
例えばもうもう釘 インドの行者やってますね
板に釘いっぱい打って
この釘の棘の上に寝るとかね
で そんな感じで この鋭い刃物に
釘にぶら下がれよと思うたびに
我々の体が怪我したり痛くなるでしょうに
ですから 体っていうのは物質だから
物質の状態がひどくなればなるほど
そこにずっと心がついてるんだから
心で痛みやら苦しみやら楽しみやら
全部心が感じるもんだから
心はずっと苦しみを感じちゃうんですね
ですから 死ぬまでは大変苦しいんです
死ぬ瞬間って何のこともないんです
で そこで執着ある人が死にたくないんですね
死にたくないっていうのは
この体を維持したいっていう気持ちなんですね
この体が欲しいんだと
この体が消えちゃったら
こういう人々と会わないんではないかと
それ執着なんです 当然なことなんですけど
人々は仲間よく仲良くしてくれるのは
この体がある限りなんです
消えちゃったら忘れてしまっちゃうんですね
そこでその人がそれでこの体が消えるのは嫌で嫌で
仲間から離れるのは嫌で
そういう執着があればあるほど
もう並ならぬ苦しみをその人は味わわなくちゃいけないんです
なぜならば 努力して努力して体に心ついてつけておこう
つけておこうとやってますから
だから死にきれない人々っていうのはすごい執着があるんですね
そこで執着なくてもカルマが強い人が過去で悪いカルマをしたりとかね
そしたら死にたいんだけど
心が止まりません エネルギーがありすぎて
例えばもう事故を起こしちゃって
体の四分の三ぐらいむちゃくちゃぺっちゃんこになってもまだ息をしているとあるんです
なかなか死ねないと それは一般用語で生命力強いやつだなと言ったりするでしょうね
あれはカルマが強いということなんですね
ですから そこでそのカルマのエネルギーは弱くなって
もう何も認識できなくなって
パッと死ぬ瞬間まで その人はすごい苦しみを味わわなくちゃいけないんです
そこで その場合も 体の苦しみと精神の苦しみ
両方あるんですね 体がガタガタで動かないし
そこで自分がもう決して治りっこはないと分かっているし
それで体と心が離れて
頭で考えると もうやっぱり治りっこはないんだ
死ぬんだとかね 頭で思っちゃうと精神的に強烈な苦しみを味わっちゃうんです
だから全ての苦しみが執着から生まれるものであって
そうでないともう苦しみとか何とか
もう何の問題もないんです
実際は で だから執着した人はずっと究極的に楽っていうことはそういう場だけなんですね
足が痛くても 腰が痛くても
まあがんになろうとも
まあ執着ない人はすごい楽で楽で楽しいんですね
それは痛い それだけで終わっちゃいますからね
だから執着ない人は 例えばもう自分がもう足が痛いんだと
これが痛いですよというだけで終わっちゃうんですね
これがこの足がね それすごく痛いんですよ
ああ 足が痛い どうしようとかはならないんですね
これから年取るんだからもっとひどくなるでしょうとか
どうしようどうしようとか
何とかしなくちゃとかはならないんです
すごく楽にいるんですね
精神的な悩みはない ですから執着なくした方が楽なんですけど
で 別に何かこの長寿 もう不良長寿
薬飲んだとかで楽になるとかはないんです
で ですから死ぬ瞬間は完全たる無意識
寝る心と同じなんです
そこで その前に この死ぬ心が生まれる前に
その人が普通に痛みやら憎しみやら嫉妬やら
いろんな感情あるでしょうに
財産は捨てたくないとかね
この財産は姑さんにだけはあげたくないとか
いろんな気持ちで死ぬ時はね
人が死んじゃいますからね
姑さんではなくて お嫁さんにはあげたくないとかね
それはだいたい世の中でごく普通にあること
ことで で あるいはもう自分の息子があまりね
まあもういい性格じゃないんだ
自分が一生もう作り上げたもう会社やらね
もうあのこいつはこれ壊すだろうとか思ったり
やっぱりどうしようかとかね
そういう悩み苦しみがあるのは意識の時なんですね
そこで意識がある時はいろんな悩みやら苦しみやら煩悩やらあったとする
そこで死ぬ心が生まれた
その時はもう何のこともなく
まあ無意識の心で安らかな心で死んじゃったと
死んでも次にその瞬間にこの人は生まれるんですね
決勝心 その決勝心がその過去の感情を対象にする
もうあれは過去なんです
仏教の過去っていうのはほんの瞬間過ぎ去ったら過去なんですからね
だから早いんだから 我々にとっては物質の流れっていうのは
ですから 過去っていうのは一時間が過去じゃなくて
一秒の中でも無数の過去があるんだから
ですから この死ぬ瞬間あって
その前で感じたもの 考えたもの
それになんとか認識して所縁にして対象にして
この決勝心が生まれるんです
ですから そこで心が決まってしまっちゃう
例えば 死ぬちょっと前にすごい嫉妬の心が生まれたならば
当然怒りの心なんですね
そうすると 嫉妬をその対象か
その心か 死ぬちょっと前にすごい気持ち悪かったと
ですから 瞬間だから 死ぬ瞬間というのは
瞬間心がこの寝たような状態になって
次にまた寝たような心が現れちゃう
それでやっぱりその心はすぐ前のことを思い出して
その流れが続きますから
ですから 新しい決勝心がちょっと前の心の影響を受けているんです
だから 今説明した通り
例えば嫉妬の心生まれたら
それは怒りの心で怒りの心
怒りに伏せばし決勝心が生まれる
ですから 怒りのエネルギーで生まれる次元に入ってしまっちゃうんです
でも当然ながら悪い心だから
決勝心は決まっていて
あのなんて言いますか
アクサライバーカサンティーラの結果なんですね
あの決勝心する心があると言ったんですね
シャブーの須弥道心ですね
二つあります 三つあります
須弥道心三つありますけど
須弥道心はシャブーは二つあります
一つは善成熟心 一つは不善成熟心
その人に不善成熟心の須弥道心が決勝心として生まれちゃう
生まれたら死ぬまでその心で頑張らなくちゃいけないんです
なぜならば 決勝心と有分心と痴心は全く同じだから
ですから 決勝心はこの須弥道心ぐらいのこの無因心というものすごい弱い心でしょうに
それでその人は大胆なことを発明したとかね
すごい頭がよく知識人になったとかありえないんです
あのエネルギーの量は死ぬまでもう同じなんです
で 頑張ればいろいろもうちょっとちょっとエネルギーの差が生まれますけど
でも大胆な変わりは生まれません
で あんまり人間の世界では須弥道心では生まれないんですが
生まれてもかなり弱い
その場合も善成熟心の須弥道心なんです
善成熟心の須弥道心に生まれる可能性あるんだけど
で 生まれても随分人間としてはもうかなり弱くて
他の人々と肩を並べることはできない
死ぬまでもできない まあ頑張って何か成功したりすることできますけどね
例えば手も動かない 足も足だけ動くんだ
足で筆を持って絵を描くとかね
それ有名になるとかできますけど
だからって本人にとってはこの体の経験にとってももう何のこともないんですよ
すごいお金入ったっても
その人に贅沢できませんし
もう決まってるんだからパターンが
人々に褒められたっても
それにちゃんと言葉を交わしてあげることもできないし
もう結局そういう頑張ることを別に仏教では大変認めてますからね
諦めるなと 何があろうとも
だからといってカルマの結果も変えることはできないんですね
あの もっとすごい頭のいいイギリスにいるホーキングさんですか
彼のカルマは一旦頑張っちゃったんだから中止しちゃったんですね
早く死ぬ運命でしたけど
諦めなかったんで本人が
別に体はもう諦めちゃって
体はそういう病気だから
もう全部筋肉が止まっちゃって死ぬだろうと
で その間は自分の仕事をするそうとね
頭だけの仕事 とことん頭だけのすごいことを研究したりしちゃったんだから
そこはいいカルマなんですね
明るくて頭行動してるんだから
それであのカルマの流れがね
一旦もうそこでストップなっちゃったんですね
だからストップなったことはありがたいことで
その先生はもう-